there's a question by shubra gupta if
kasparov plays the required 30 classical
games
by may can you also qualify for
candidates it's a good question like i
guess he's listed as inactive but even
plays 30 games
i mean technically
again right yeah technically yes but he
would you know
uh ding did not actually need to
be on six and a half out of seven in
that tournament that he's currently
playing in
uh gary on the other hand probably would
need to score you know
how long is gary 2840 or something
isn't gary 2840 or something
is he
i thought or maybe ia okay so i'm
i'm trying to retire with a pretty high
rating yeah i'm i'm trying to figure out
why the numbers in my head weren't that
i guess it's because his uh he's only
two at 12 sparrow only
so it would be a race between ding and
kasparov yeah but if kasparov plays
these 30 games against the 1600 player
yeah
it's right there
yeah i think it's i'm
all of those are sound points i was just
trying to figure out the bug in my in my
brain and
i think it's because his rapid rating
stayed active for longer and his rapid
rating is not 28 something it's 27
something now would magnus defend his
title against gary
there were multiple brain bugs all right
yeah i don't know magnus against gary
it's hard to say no as well but
gary needs to play 30 games in april
which i guess is unlikely then he needs
to win the candidates
um
no it's it does sound
like it's not going to happen
gary 30 wrong match with carpool that
would
not be a good idea